AGAINST.
NEWT GINGRICH, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> WE TURN TO MORE FAR LEFT NEWS
OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
SAN FRANCISCO REPARATIONS
COMMITTEE IS PROPOSING A $5
MILLION IT EACH BLACK LONG-TIME
RESIDENT.
NOT TOTAL BUT $5 MILLION TO EACH
BLACK RESIDENT INCLUDING TOTAL
DEBT FORGIVENESS.
THE PLAN CALLS FOR THE CITY TO
SUPPLEMENT LOW INCOME BLACK
RESIDENTS FOR THE NEXT 250
YEARS.
HERE'S LEO TERRELL AND LARRY
ELDER.
LEO, DOES EVERY BAD IDEA COME
OUT OF CALIFORNIA?
HOW DO THEY IMAGINE THIS WOULD
GET IMPLEMENTED?
>> IT WON'T EVER GET
IMPLEMENTED.
YOU WILL BE THE FIRST LAWYER TO
FIGHT AGAINST THIS.
52 IS OUTRAGEOUS.
IT'S UNLAWFUL AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT'S RACIST BUT NOT SURPRISING
IT CAME FROM CALIFORNIA.
ON THE DAY OF MLK'S BIRTHDAY WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT A RACIST
PROGRAM TO BENEFIT INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAPPEN TO BE BLACK.
$5 MILLION.
CALIFORNIA WAS A FREE STATE.
WHO WILL PAY FOR IT IF WHY
SHOULD THEY GET $5 MILLION?
BECAUSE OF SKIN COLOR?
IT'S RACIST.
THEY TRIED TO PASS PROP 16 AN
OLD VERSION OF AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
IT LOST.
IT'S UNFAIR TO BENEFIT ONE GROUP
OVER ANOTHER BECAUSE OF SKIN
COLOR.
SOMEONE SAID JUDGE A PERSON BY
THE CHARACTER OF HIS CONDUCT AND
NOT THE COLOR OF HIS SKIN.
THAT'S THE PERSON WE SHOULD BE
FOLLO
FOLLOWING.
NOT GIVING PEOPLE $5 MILLION
BASED ON SKIN COLOR.
>> THAT'S THE PERSON WE HONOR
TODAY.
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.
LARRY, WE LAUGH.
THIS IS WHAT LARGE PORTIONS OF
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY WOULD LIKE TO
PUSH POLITICALLY.
NOT JUST IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
ELSEWHERE.
TAXPAYERS PAY FOR THE SINCE OF
THE PAST AS IF THAT WOULD MAKE
THINGS BETTER.
>> REPARATIONS IS EXTRACTION
EVER MONEY FROM PEOPLE WHO NEVER
SLAVE OWNERS TO PEOPLE WHO WERE
NEVER SLAVES.
THIS BUSINESS ABOUT
SUPPLEMENTING INCOME FOR THE
NEXT 250 YEARS?
WHERE DID THAT COME FROM?
THAT'S FUZZY MATH.
SAN FRANCISCO WAS NOT A SLAVE
CITY.
ONLY ABOUT 5% OF WHITE AMERICANS
ARE CONNECTED TO SLAVERY.
SLAVERY WAS A DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTION.
FEW REPUBLICANS OWN SLAVED.
IT'S INSULTING.
WHAT IS NEXT GIVE CALIFORNIA
BACK TO MEXICO?
HONESTLY.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> AMERICA DOESN'T HAVE A RACE
ISSUE.
AMERICA HAS A RACE CARD ISSUE.
THE DEMOCRATS NEED TO PLAY THE
RACE CARD.
WITHOUT THE BLACK POPULATION
THERE IS NO DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY HAVE A RACE CARD ISSUE.
THEY WILL NEVER LET THAT CARD
GO.
THIS COUNTRY AS NO SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
BUT YOU CAN'T TELL THAT TO
A DEMOCRAT.
>> LEO, DO YOU AGREE?
THAT'S A STRONG STATEMENT THIS
IS BEING MADE UP TO FURTHER
DIVIDE US?
>> ABSOLUTELY!
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
>> SORRY, LARRY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THE DEMOCRATS KEEP GETTING THAT
BLACK VOTE, 95%.
WITHOUT WHICH THEY CANNOT WIN.
INSTEAD OF CONCENTRATING ON THE
PROBLEMS IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY
THE ABSENCE OF FATHERS AND CRIME
IN URBAN AREAS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT NONSENSE ABOUT
MAKING OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH JIM CROW AND
SLAVERY PLAY MONEY TO BLACK
PEOPLE TO KEEP GETTI